but things are going to get worse if you
look at the acceleration
of the number of cases the seven day
average has gone up substantially
democrats ignoring warnings like that
from top biden officials and are now
being called major coveted hypocrites
after a weekend of breaking their own
rules
washington dc mayor muriel bowser was
spotted maskless at a wedding after
reinstating her city's mandate to cover
up just hours before
and chicago mayor lori lightfoot was
masculist posing with celebrities at
lollapalooza
after threatening new covet restrictions
she is also being criticized for
allowing that massive outdoor music
festival
in the first place plus former president
obama reportedly defined cdc guidance
for his 60th birthday party nearly 500
guests have been invited to the bash and
at least 200 workers and
are expected to staff the event just to
get a point on that
jen saki the white house press secretary
commented on the obama party take a look
former president obama has been a huge
advocate of
individuals getting vaccinated this
event according to all the public
reporting
is outdoors and in a moderate zone the
guidance is about
what steps people can take when they're
in public settings
indoor settings specifically was the new
guidance jesse did you get an invite
no but that's the hottest ticket of the
summer for sure the big story about that
is that
barack didn't invite joe that's cold
no they were best buddies for eight
years and i could see trump not inviting
pence to a birthday party but barack not
inviting
joe biden either they're not on speaking
terms or
barack obama doesn't want anybody more
powerful than he
is at the party i can understand that
like if i had a birthday party would i
invite hannity hell no
i don't want everybody sucking up to
sean i want them sucking up to me
the other thing they have is a covid
coordinator
yeah at the party a new thing so what is
that person supposed to do shoot eric
holder
in the head with a temperature gun oh
you can go eric
what are they going to tell spike lee to
sneeze downwind it's like a useless job
they probably make more than i do pearl
jams performing
barack doesn't like pearl jam oh pearl
jam's not
of course they're not because michelle
doesn't like pearl jam
that doesn't make any sense i love how
you were able to party i love how you
were able to pivot
from when you found out that you weren't
dependent on her i was like
canceled yeah girl jim i can't believe
they're having oh they're not it's her
fault
i sort of felt like with president obama
hasn't been out there saying
put mass back on he doesn't have any
power anymore he's saying i'm vaccinated
my friends are vaccinated i'm throwing a
party isn't that what we should be doing
yes in fact i'm going to take this as a
a uh
he's the leader and he's telling
americans it's time it's okay
not only is covet over so is climate
change
right because think about between 500
700 people how many private jets are
going to be landed in that tiny airport
so we now know that do not let do not
let the last you know the
the threats of impending doom keep you
from your 60th birthday party
i am by the way i'm totally for it but i
do think it's like
why does so i mean it does president
obama former president still need
more love does he need another hey
wonderful think about all the
celebrities
that are going to be there it's just it
is just going to be halloween
well you know i'm not going unless
tucker's going i got my ticket he hasn't
gotten his yet so
what do you think about mayor bowser i
mean this is
lori lightfoot to some extent but i
think mayor bowser i think that was the
one it's just like
we've seen this movie before because she
because she made the deadline after the
wedding which was like we weren't
supposed to notice that which was
hilarious it used to be that laws were
for everyone
not so anymore we have we only have laws
for the law abiding
have you thought about this no we don't
have any laws anymore
for people who really need them meaning
the criminals and politicians
so when there's a dramatic surge in
crime the instinct is to go after the
criminal if you're common sense
but instead they talk about creating
more laws
for gun crime for basically laws that
will be followed by the law abiding
so every all the suggestions and
everything that we hear and the orders
that we are given
they're for people that you know are
going to do the right thing
but no one ever pressures the people who
are doing the wrong thing
to do with it right politicians and
criminals no different
the move at the wedding greg is to
always have a drink in your hand
so
richard what did you think about the dc
scandal du jour i like jesse's solution
to the problem
oh it was rather funny no i i think the
mayor here uh
according to her statement from rafa she
said that she had a mask on the whole
time the picture shows a little
different
so i think that's a little bit
problematic her social media team is
like oh yeah
i can only imagine if i was under comp
scene i'd be pretty pissed too
but listen i think there i'm not a fan
of mayor de blasio but his
how he's sort of approaching this i
think is the right way to do it what he
said today was look
i strongly encourage folks that are
vaccinated to wear mask indoors if you
can
because we want to stop the spread of
the covered variant but i will not in
the city of new york put out a masked
mandate and i think that's the right way
to go
you're told not true if you're trying to
encourage folks to get vaccinated which
is what the goal here is the goal is to
encourage people to get vaccinated
especially
when we had a week where florida
reported its highest number of coveted
cases
in a single day in the entirety of this
pandemic right and we also know that
there's ten thousand people in florida
over that
that are currently being hospitalized
and the only way we're going to stop
this
is via vaccination understand that the
vaccination is more effective than the
actual coveted treatments if you catch
covenant being hospitalized
then we're going to have to do it with
sort of a carrot and not a stick
vaccinations are up i mean
yeah they are they're in a two-week high
they can make it late but they met their
deadlines
70 of the first shot by july first it
was august first i mean
yeah they're meeting those goals but uh
i think
when you look at the way that people's
lives are being controlled and these big
questions about kids going back to
school and the teachers unions demanding
that kids be masked
the panic pushers on kovid are
not afraid of covet apparently the
people like mayor bowser or
gavin newsom in california as the
governor they've never been afraid
of this in the way that they're pushing
it on everybody else and acting like
everybody needs to be terrified about it
and i think the question is well why not
because if it's as serious as they are
saying
while they're trying to regulate every
aspect of your lives you would think
that they would also be taking it
seriously but they have not been taking
it seriously
over the weekend it was more important
for her to go hang out with dave
chappelle and to be at this wedding
and then they go after the reporter who
was there and say that she she wasn't
invited and how dare she
report the news so when there are big
decisions being made by the cdc director
by the white house talking about
mandates when you had one of the
the white house's top covid advisors
today who's from the university of
minnesota saying that the mass that
we're wearing the non
n95 masks aren't working to slow the
spread
well when they put these government
mandates in place and they encourage
small businesses or corporations to do
the same you're affecting people's lives
you're affecting their livelihood you're
affecting kids ability to go back to
school and have social interaction with
each other
and so i think it's a bigger question of
why are they acting like everyone needs
to panic
and possibly lock down again and do all
these things
when they are not doing them and they're
implementing rules that no none of them
are affected by they're not affect you
know the people going to barack obama's
birthday party
aren't affected by these rules they can
fly on their private jet they can have
things delivered
all the people who are mandating these
issues
skirt the rules or they aren't affected
by that it affects real people it is
like a it's an
interesting kind of class warfare yeah
in the sense that
the they are they you can tell people to
do the things that you yourself can
endure
but they can't and they will have to do
and over time their lives get worse
but and i didn't put myself in that of
the exemption i was able to work all the
way through this yeah we were able to
work from home that's why we
like we were like wanted to get back
here because you know we were we're
giving
advice to people and yet we're not being
we're not taking the advice is
hypocrites imagine if you're a
restaurant owner who
got through this yeah and is now looking
at the possibility
of you as the president said that today
there might be more restrictions coming
in say lockdowns he said restrictions i
think there's a balanced approach here i
think what the cdc could be doing is
saying
in places where there's a high infection
rate and there's a low vaccination rate
here's the threshold when you get to
this point you have to go back to
and when you get to this point you have
to go back to lockdown so it's very
clear everybody knows what the threshold
is
everybody knows what's going to happen
when you get there so people aren't in a
lurch when a random press release comes
out from the cdc but it's not
the cds stop talking it's not no it's
not clear right now they gave you the
county by county map and according to
those guidelines
every single city right now you have to
wear a mask according to their guide i
agree with i mean that's crazy i'm
agreeing with you on that point
crazy that you're agreeing with me
richard
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else